سبعه دول عربيه تستعد خلال الايام القليله
المقبله لاستقبال قبه حراريه وستصبح
الاجواء فيها حاره جدا المنظمه العالميه
للارصاد الجويه التابعه للامم المتحده
اشارت ان الكتله الحاره ستؤثر على مصر
والعراق والسعوديه وسوريا ولبنان والاردن
وفلسطين اعتبارا من نهايه الاسبوع الجاري
خطوره القبه الحراريه تتمثل في ارتباطها
بنمط الطقس الراكد الذي يؤدي الى ظواهر
مثل ارتفاع نسب الرطوبه والحراره لدرجه
كبيره ما يقلل قدره الانسان على التعامل
معها وتاتي تلك التحذيرات في وقت تعلن فيه
الاداره الوطنيه الامريكيه لدراسه
المحيطات والغلاف الجوي ان الصيف الحالي
سيشهد اعلى درجات حراره على كوكب الارض
منذ
136 عاما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]